Hola buenas noches Sí con 59 46 firmas
requeridas para solicitar formalmente el
juicio político la bancada de oposición
ha presentado ante la gestión documental
de la asamblea nacional el pedido para
enjuiciar así el presidente de la
república presenta esta solicitud de
juicio político cuatro de las cinco
bancadas que hacen en vida en la
asamblea nacional el partido unes que
convoca a el correísmo el partido social
cristiano que eran antiguos aliados al
presidente de la república una fracción
del pachacútec el cual agrupa los
movimientos indígenas y la izquierda
democrática formalmente comienzan así lo
que es la solicitud de juicio político
contra el presidente de la república
posteriormente Entonces qué es lo que va
a pasar será un hecho o no Bueno esto
debe cumplir con un procedimiento por
parte de la normativa legal del Ecuador
Leal El presidente de la asamblea
nacional Virgilio tiene tres días para
presentar ante el órgano calificador de
la asamblea nacional este pedido de
juicio político ante este órgano que
posteriormente debe revisar si cumple
con los requisitos de ley para
presentarlo ante la Corte constitucional
posteriormente entonces la corte
constitucional debe decidir en un
periodo de seis días Si cumple o no con
estos requisitos legales para indicar si
habrá o no un juicio político en total
de considerar positivo para comenzar con
juicio político el presidente de
república podría ser destituido por un
proceso que se extenderá por 55 días
Bueno acusan a lazo de presunta
corrupción y malversación Pero entonces
qué han dicho desde el ejecutivo tras
este anuncio
bueno específicamente el informe
presentado ante la asamblea nacional
dice que actualmente el presidente de la
república conocía sobre ciertas
investigaciones que en principio
conformaron parte de una investigación
de tráfico de drogas y posteriormente
también ha tenido puntos que es resalta
que el presidente de la república a
solapado una investigación que tenía
conocimiento y que ha defendido a su
entorno
íntimo y ha solapado también
investigaciones de presunta corrupción
en la empresa pública dice
específicamente el documento y Leo
textualmente nosotros establecemos
responsabilidades políticas y hemos
presentado este juicio político porque
los hechos fácticos y se relacionan
circunstancialmente De igual forma se
dispone a actuar de acuerdo a la
Constitución y se dice ha protegido
vínculos de una estructura criminal en
las empresas públicas Pero qué es lo que
dice El Ejecutivo nacional Hace algunos
minutos El Ejecutivo nacional ha emitido
un pronunciamiento formal en rechazo a
este juicio político y dice
específicamente se rechaza el juicio
político carece de sustentos tanto
políticos como jurídico para sustentar
así un proceso en contra el presidente
de la república por el cual considera
que este juicio político tiene
exclusivamente intenciones
desestabilizadores encontraría la
democracia ha dicho Hace algunos minutos
el gobierno nacional